welcome to America's vanished children
I'm your host Carol Healy our show
focuses on missing children and we need
your help to provide us with leads it
might aid the recovery of these children
now tonight we're going to be talking
with three parents who are searching for
their daughters we're going to hear a
little bit about their ongoing
investigations and we're going to show
you photos of these children and others
and give you the number for the National
Center for Missing and Exploited
Children should you have any information
regarding these children or others that
number is 1-888-886-8632 and a half but
I'd like to go through what she was
wearing on that day that day amber was
wearing purple cords a white
short-sleeved t-shirt with teal colored
bands around these sleeves and the
bottom of the shirt with multicolored
pictures of sunglasses on the front pink
socks and white and pink elegir tennis
shoes it was approximately 4:15 on June
through 1988 when amber went out to jump
rope in the front yard
approximately 4:30 when I went out to
check on her she was gone 15 minutes
later correct
right no one saw anything I was home I
didn't even hear anything
amber is hearing-impaired was not
wearing her hearing aid at the time so
she would speak in a kind of a nasally
tone and that's something that she'll
still have now I mean that
impairments permanent so her voice will
be different right right
she also suffers from migraines or at
least she did four and a half years ago
so if she happens to be a child taken
into a hospital you know with with
migraines happens to be a child with
migraines and as hearing impaired that
would that would sure you know be a clue
that it could be amber another thing
since it's four and a half years later
and she's grown and your family people
tend to be pretty tall so is it pretty
likely that she's probably tall now
right if you judge by her older brother
who is very tall and thin and the fact
that her father and myself are taller
than her father was chances are amber
would be now you recently started
something something positive out of all
of is called the amber foundation can
you tell us something about that correct
the amber foundation was formed just a
few months after amber was taken I had
the need basically to be very involved
what was happening with my daughter to
deal with stranger cases or unknown and
with the sub issues of what is happening
to these children to enlighten the
public as to what is happening to
educate children on how to be safe what
you do at amber day I know recently
Pinole hosted amber day right and our
events amber day is always in August
somewhere very close to Amber's birthday
which is the 19th it is basically a
function put together to to get families
together to come to one large location
where they can get their children
fingerprinted videoed pick up
information not only from our
organization but from other missing
children organizations throughout
California to listen to speakers such as
Police Department's FBI and families of
other missing kids so that you can give
advice to other families about how they
should not leave their children in cars
correct what other kinds of things do
people take for granted and do all the
time they brothers shouldn't lots of
latchkey kids nowadays so if your child
is left at home they should be
instructed not to answer the door but if
somebody phones to say that you know
you're unavailable can they take a
message never say that you're alone to
walk with crowds of kids or you know in
a group which in some cases doesn't even
help
at least you know you've got more kids
there the chances of your child being
stolen are much less than if they were
walking alone to teach kids that they
are not to go anywhere with anyone at
any time that includes going to an extra
neighbor's house for a cookie and a
glass of milk because you just you just
don't know if you could have a pedophile
living right next door to you and not
know it now do you still get any leads
in Amber's case yes we do I've done
quite a few programs such as this and a
lot of national programs the most recent
was on the 13th of November was
America's Most Wanted from that
particular show we've generated over 200
calls for Amber so we still have calls
that come in on a daily basis and she's
registered with many organizations on a
national level so they received lots of
calls also now if you had something
quick to say to other parents out there
any particular quick advice you could
get them fingerprints your kid keep
updated photos of your children maybe
even you know pull a few strings of hair
out of their head and keep those you
know for potential you know information
that the FBI or police would need in the
event that their child is missing I want
to thank you for being with us thank you
for sharing your story and now we're
going to show two photos of two other
missing children and have the Center for
national the National Center for Missing
and Exploited Children on the screen as
well this is Gina
dawn Brooks she's a Caucasian female
with blond hair green eyes she
disappeared on August 5th 1989 that was
four years ago at the time she was 13
years old now she'll be 17 again that
was four years ago and her hair was
blonde at the time it could be it could
be any color now it could be short take
a look at that photo although it was
long at the time it could have been cut
and dyed in any number of ways at the
time of her disappearance when she was
13 she weighed a hundred hundred and
eight pounds she could have increased in
weight she could weigh less we're not
sure Gina was
last seen riding her bike in
Fredericktown Maryland and the bike was
found abandoned if you have any
information call that number on your
screen that's one eight hundred eighty
four three five six seven eight
this is Michaelmas away Michael is a
Filipino male he was last seen on
January 25th 1989 at the time Michael
was 16 years old again that was four
years ago he was 5 feet tall he weighed
160 pounds he has black hair brown eyes
again this was four years ago Michael
would now be about 20 years old and he
may look greatly different he
disappeared from San Francisco
California and he may have changed in
appearance he may be heavier
we're not sure but take a good look at
that photo he has glasses he probably
still has glasses take a good look at
that photo his hair may be short call
that number if you have any information
at all Michael mouths away that's one
eight hundred eighty seven eight we're
going to take a short break and when we
come back we're going to be talking with
another family searching for their
daughter stay tuned
[Music]
many children after they are either
Runaways or kidnapped must turn or are
forced into prostitution here are
sections from a previous program we did
on the subject investigations and other
cities have shown that boys 13 14 even
younger are coerced into prostitution
with threats of physical violence and
are sometimes shipped across state lines
shipped to the older adult men who
desire young boys for sexual acts
occasionally these boys episodes with
their older clients ends and physical
violence there are men who seek young
boys to torture and sometimes to kill
the President's Commission on obscenity
found this is the commission that
Richard Nixon repudiated it mentioned in
passing that child pornography was a
phenomenon of the abuse of children and
then went on to say that for every
female prostitute of any age in the
United States there are nine boys
underage who are prostitutes there was a
call boy ring operated out of New York
City which had phone hookups with
Houston Atlanta Los Angeles New Orleans
Washington DC and that call boy ring had
a list of 10,000 clients who could call
and with a credit card purchase a boy
hello hello this is a credit card number
oh six seven eight nine I'd like to make
an order please go ahead I'm looking for
a young male blond hair blue eyes body
hair nobody here thick body hair please
what age 10 to 12
put your femme books what is your
address I'm at the Houston Marriott
hotel room 313 wire me 200 dollars now
by credit card they have a hundred
dollars in cash for the boy he'll be
there in 30 minutes thank you thank you
in Houston I give the figure based on I
think
prudent calculations that upwards of
three hundred and fifty boys a year are
killed
deliberately because of this many more
died of drug overuse value malnutrition
of suicide the national toll per year is
in the thousands every year kids die
violently because of this kind of
individuals involved are down the line
almost in every instance in the cases
I've investigated men who are very
powerful usually very wealthy and
usually administrate control over a
large number of people sixteen-year-old
boy came to us and telling how he'd
started as a prostitute at age twelve
and now is employed by a large Houston
in cooperation the corporation pays him
from a well covered slush fund I'm
working right now you know like just
yeah with the corporation and what's
that how's that work well when they're
executives or you know their business
people are in town they're sent to our
apartment and we entertain them while
they're here okay what's that
entertainment usually involved what do
they usually demand or what do they want
well it's all kinds of sex and
perversions there's no - like I've
decided that subsequent to the making of
this interview this boys mutilated body
was found it's closely attached to the
major financial commercial industrial
educational institutions of our society
it's run by the same people who run
those it's frequented by the same people
who occupy management positions in those
it's not the Mafia it's it's an adjunct
of clean business it's serving the most
respectable people we have in our
society the people who are the elite
young boy prostitutes 14 and 15 years
old explained one reason they sell their
bodies to older men is for money for
some especially the runaways the money
means survival a child and adolescent
psychiatrist explained another
motivation as revenge against a father
stepfather or older man who sexually
molested
at an earlier age best information I
have is that these kids die they waste
away they kill themselves somebody kills
them that's it and we're talking about
over half over half of the kids who make
their living this way for a period don't
survive adolescence welcome back joining
us now are Ann and Jim Campbell
searching parents of Amanda Nikki
Campbell welcome to the show and in Jim
now I've got questions for you but
before we get into that we want to show
a photo of Nikki as she was last
December 27th when she disappeared she
was four years old about five-and-a-half
about 3 feet tall she'll be five and a
half now she was three feet six inches
tall than 65 pounds she was wearing a
pink jacket a purple top purple pants
she had long blonde hair probably in a
ponytail with bangs she has a big smile
great big smile big dimples now her hair
may have changed she may be a different
height now because she's five and a half
now and she could have they could have
cut her hair
collared it and they can change her you
know in a number of ways she's grown
over a year now she's on yes now take me
back to that day and tell me a little
bit about what happened on December 27
1991 I came home from work finding my 16
year old at the garage door telling me
that Jim was unable to locate Nikki I
proceeded to go to her friend's house
that she was allowed to go to unable to
contact and get ahold of Nikki and I
came back home that meeting Sheila's
daddy at my driveway he said let's go
call the police and when we got there my
16 year old said mom I've already called
the police they immediately came out and
did a door-to-door search until 1:00 in
the morning still unable to locate
Amanda and they came back the next
morning and started to search over again
at 6:00 a.m. so they searched for two
days during a door asking everybody they
searched actually three days three days
they did it Friday evening Saturday and
Sunday now they also did a helicopter
search as they did a helicopter search
they also did they brought the dogs in
which carried the son of my dog
and also the set of her at a vehicle and
what did the dogs find the dogs led them
that she was taken out of the
neighborhood to the nearest McDonald's
and onto i-80 West which is exactly 90
seconds from my front door and after
that the trail disappeared after that
the trip yes because they cannot take
the dogs on the freeway now who was the
detective who was working with you on
this case take detective Harold Sagan
out of Fairfield Police Department how
do you how do you feel about him he's
been fantastic he's done a lot of work
and research an investigation and
continues to work on leads and following
up on information that he has on
locating Nicky he's still working on it
yes
he said he knows my daughter as well as
I do now now I know you have what three
other boys I have three other boys and
this is of course had a great big impact
on them tell me a little bit about how
it's affected your family um we just
live one day at a time we have Matthew
who is Nicky's brother he is six years
old and he we have to go on for him he
is very important and they all say their
sister's going to come home they just
don't know when so this is how you live
each day at a time you got to go on for
the rest of your family that's right and
then I work with Friends of Amanda
Campbell which Kevin Collins set up
right after Nikki disappeared and what
we do is we address and stamp envelopes
mailing out her flyer to all the
businesses across the United States and
I will continue to do this until the day
she is found thanks so much for being
with us I have to go now to show you two
more photos of other missing children
and we'll have the Center for Missing
and Exploited Children that numbers
going to be on the screen for you this
is Eileen Mitchell HOF we have two
photos of Eileen one taken when she
approximately when she disappeared
January 30th 1989 she was 16 at the time
and one as an age progressed photo she's
about 20 now and she's probably changed
dramatically Eileen was last seen in
Dublin California on Monday January 30th
1989 she was wearing a charcoal gray
pullover polo sweater a horizontally
striped pink and grey skirt black low
top
and carrying a dark blue backpack again
she's now 20 years old she's probably
changed to great deal Eileen is white
with brown hair curly brown hair and
brown eyes and weighed about 115 pounds
she wore braces this is Jacob
Irwin Wetterling Jacob was abducted at
gunpoint on October 22nd 1989 from st.
Joseph Minnesota the abductor was
described as a male wearing dark
clothing and a mask over his face Jacob
was 13 years old at the time five feet
tall and weighed 75 pounds he has a slim
build brown hair blue eyes a mole on his
left cheek and a scar on his knee we
have an aged progressed photo of Jacob
at the age of 15 he'd be approximately
16 now we're going to take a short break
now's a good time if you haven't before
go ahead and get a pencil or a pen jot
down that number that's on our screen
for the National Center for Missing and
Exploited Children give them a call if
you have any information to relate when
we come back we're going to have a
success story newborn baby who was
abducted from the hospital was recently
recovered reunited with her parents stay
tuned we'll be right back
[Music]
children are the largest group of
Americans living below the poverty they
have to reach higher for what others
take for granted health care balanced
meals encouragement to learn but with
help early on children in your community
can gain the skills to get out from
below the poverty line
it takes programs like success by 6:00
and people like you to help them take
the first step
call to learn more change the world of a
child and you change the world you know
that
of them of the 28 million people in this
country living in official poverty 24
million are women are kids and by the
year 2000 of this trend continues and
under Reagan it will not only continue
but accelerate the entire poverty
population will be us and our kids
that's violence and that fifty percent
of women in relationships with men are
beaten by them that means anything from
just a slap in the face to merger and
that one out of three women can expect
to be raped in her lifetime and that one
out of four women under the age of girls
or females under the age of 18 before
they reach age 18 will be sexually
abused in sexually abused by some member
of their families or father grandpa for
one out of War one out of force
absolutely absolutely an epidemic so
think of these little children that are
molested as little ones one out of three
females are molested before they're 18
years old and that's just from the
reported cases one out of five males it
I just worked with a man a nurse in the
hospital molested him when he was a
child it's everywhere it's it's it's
unbelievable and our system is in denial
they don't want to see this and to see
it they have to see their own so you
really want to make sure you know who
the people are with your children right
before I came here a case broke out and
date and a teacher in a Catholic school
which scared maybe is I send my children
to private schools was molesting
molesting the kid this happened right as
I'm sitting here this just broke in
Dayton Ohio well usually we hear about
men molesting little girls little boys
do women do this women do it as well yes
they do oka beat teacher it could be the
coach it could be the doctor that you go
to
On June 12th of 1992 a parent's worst
nightmare came true a newborn baby was
abducted from her mother by a woman who
posed as an employee for WIC a County
program for women infants and children
the woman approached the baby's mother
Jessica mommy nee while she was in a
room at a Berkeley Hospital and
persuaded Jessica to allow her to take
baby carryout for standard Hospital
procedures hundreds of volunteers help
search for baby Kari by creating fliers
and making the public aware of the
abduction a public plea for the return
of their daughter was made by baby
Carrie's mother Jessica and her father
Christy array Rosales
as a search stretched into weeks and
then months hope for the child returned
it begun to fade
but due to public awareness Kari was
found three months later if dr. Karen
Lee Hughes was taken into custody and
Carrie's mother was notified that her
daughter had been found in healthy
condition
with her baby back in her arms Jessica
can once again look forward to
motherhood
that was a wonderful recovery story I
hope we can add many more now I'm joined
by Georgia Hill gammon she's the
executive director of the vanished
children's alliance
welcome to the show Georgia thank you
the pleasure being here now the vanished
Children's Alliance was involved in the
baby carry recovery case we were
involved in the case during the three
months that baby Kari was missing and
baby Kari I'm happy to say was located
as a result of a tip from a neighbor to
the of the abductor who was aware that
baby Kari was missing and became
suspicious when this when her neighbor
showed up with the child that did not
seem to be hers and the stories were
conflicting so after a thousand
sightings and baby Kari there was in
fact one tip that led to the happy
reunion of mother and child that's
something important for our viewers to
keep in mind I mean if they see
something suspicious they can do
something about it absolutely and we are
absolutely in need of the public to
participate in assisting the efforts to
bring children home and what would you
suggest if somebody see something
suspicious who should they call Venice
Children's Alliance they should call
number one their law enforcement agency
they can contact the vanna's Children's
Alliance at 1-800 vanished we have a
toll free sliding line and we will then
take that information get into the
proper hands now baby Carrie's been
reunited with her parents and they're
doing well they're doing real well and
as a matter of fact a week after the
recovery was able to hold baby Kerry in
my arms at a picnic so it was it was the
realization that in fact all our efforts
bring a child home and that is very
rewarding
now tell me how you became involved with
vanished Children's Alliance I became
involved because of a personal
experience I had a missing child for
four and a half years and as a result of
that personal experience after she was
located I became involved in the
formation of this organization which
today is a national organization dealing
with the prevention location and
reunification of missing children one of
the things that made you build the
Venice Children's Alliance there was
nothing to help you there were no
organizations that I was aware of in
those
and I was left my own resources to try
to locate my child and I made a lot of
mistakes I'm actually sort of graduated
from the school of hard knocks and
through that what I learned I've been
able to put into an agency and educate
staff and trained law enforcement
agencies on improved ways of locating
children there are several different
categories of missing children can you
tell me a little bit about that yes the
three main categories of missing
children are those children that run
away from home the second category are
those children that are taken by family
members usually non-custodial parents
and the smallest category however
perhaps the most endangered are those
children that are taken by non family
members people who are not related to
the children may be known by the
children or unknown by the children
maybe someone in the community someone
walking up and down the street walking
their puppy every day or a neighbor that
person is known to the child so that
person is not a stranger but that person
could in fact be the person responsible
for taking a child away so one of the
things you'd like to do through vanish
Children's Alliance and the other
agencies is educate parents and their
children about what a stranger is what
an acquaintance is exactly all types of
safety information is important to be
known by community members and the
public at large one of the things I
wanted to find out is what people in the
community can look for what kinds of
things can they be alerted to that might
be a Miss that might tell them that
something needs to be investigated here
when a child shows up to a home where
there wasn't a child before when the
child's identity seems to be changed a
child uses different names or the
child's hair has been dyed or a little
boys dressed up as a little girl when
something seems different I think it's
important that the public sort of follow
that instinct and that gut reaction and
to take some do something about it and
contact law enforcement contact the
vanna's Children's Alliance just don't
forget about it because it could mean
the difference between a child remaining
missing and a child coming home if you
had advice to give to parents just a
little capsule to tell parents give me
just a few seconds
I would say develop communication with
your child so there is an open flow of
communication
do not leave young children unattended
and listen to your children listen to
them because they may be giving you
messages about what's occurring in the
community Thank You Georgia and - we
have two more children that we'd like to
show you on our screen will show you
their photos and give you the Center for
the National Center for Missing and
Exploited Children thank you
this is Jennifer Nicole Paterson
Jennifer was last seen in Spring Lake
North Carolina on June 23rd 1991 she's a
white female approximately nine years
old four feet five inches tall weighing
about sixty pounds her hair and eyes are
brown
she has a freckle on the end of her nose
and a small scar on her right temple and
a scar between her eyes this is Charles
Arlen Henderson last seen on July 25th
1991 in Moscow Mills Missouri
Charles is four feet six inches tall and
weighs approximately 75 pounds he has
blond hair and blue eyes he was 11 years
old at the time of his disappearance he
has a slender build a light complexion
he was last seen wearing a camouflage
t-shirt with camouflage pants his hair
was cut in a crew-cut if you have any
information call the number on your
screen any information we can get from
you is of course very important but
equally important is prevention
so here's been with some safety tips for
your family to prevent child abductions
my name is Ben and welcome to safety
tips I hope you practice these safety
tips because you're going to need to
know them number one my family uses a
secret code word if anybody comes to
pick me up at school and they don't know
the secret code word then I don't go
with them even if I know them number two
my parents tell me to use the buddy
system and walk and play in groups
because their safety in numbers
number three my parents said if an adult
tells me a secret then I can tell them
because they're my friends
number four my parents say that if a
guide comes up to you or a lady comes up
to you and says they're a police officer
then they've got to have a badge a
uniform at a police car number five my
parents taught me the three rules if I
ever get in a dangerous situation number
one I can say no number two I can run
away screaming help
number three I'll tell a trusted adult
number six when I'm home alone
I keep the doors and windows locked
thank you and practice these safety tips
please thanks for watching our show
tonight I hope we've given you a whole
new awareness of the issue of missing
children again call that number on our
screen that's the 1-800 number for the
National Center for Missing and
Exploited Children the information you
might have doesn't have to be limited to
children that we've featured tonight if
you have information regarding any
missing children at all please give us a
call thanks again for watching
I'm your host Carol Healy and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
you lost little boy
[Music]
- Victor this isn't just a drawing it's
a cry for help listen to the children
learn to protect them from drugs and
violence call now and take a bite out of
crime